We Begin this morning with President
Biden's second State of the Union
Address his first in a
republican-controlled house
it spoke about what he believes are his
achievements from his first two years in
office including some encouraging signs
for the economy and proposed what he
called a blueprint to rebuild America
he pleaded for bipartisanship but parts
of his speech were met with heckling
from some members of the GOP Nancy
Cordes is at the White House this
morning with more on the speech Nancy
good morning good morning David yes this
may have been the rowdiest State of the
Union in history President Biden was
literally yelled at repeatedly by some
of his opponents in other ways though
this felt like a soft launch of his
re-election bid laying out his past
accomplishments and describing what he
wants to do with the rest of this term
the president of the United States
President Biden's second State of the
Union Address started with a show of
bipartisanship as he congratulated the
new house Speaker Republican Kevin
McCarthy speaker I don't want to ruin
your reputation but I look forward to
working with you but the night quickly
took a turn
of course he had to shush members of his
own party at least four times as they
booed and interrupted the president when
he talked about China
about Fentanyl
and when he noted that some Republicans
have proposed cutting Medicare and
Social Security well I'm glad to see you
now I tell you I enjoy conversion so
folks
as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is off the off
the books now right
all right with a re-election bid likely
right around the corner the president
focused on economic improvements an
unemployment rate is a 3.4 percent of
50-year low
and he touted the 1.2 trillion dollar
bipartisan infrastructure law which is
already paying to modernize roads
Bridges and more I want to thank my
Republican friends who voted for the law
and my Republican friends who voted
against it as well
but I'm still I I still get asked to
fund the projects in those districts as
well but don't worry
I promised I'd be a president for all
Americans we'll fund these projects the
president did make one quick reference
to the suspected Chinese spy balloon
that was shot down off the coast of
South Carolina over the weekend if China
threatens our sovereignty we will act to
protect our country and we did attending
the address as guests of the president
were the parents of Tyree Nichols
welcome
foreign
was beaten to death last month five
Memphis police officers are now facing
charges I know most cops and their
families are good decent honorable
people the vast majority but what
happened to Tyree in Memphis happens too
often let's come together to finish the
job on police reform he is simply unfit
to serve as commander-in-chief
delivering the Republican response was
Sarah Huckabee Sanders she is the new
governor of Arkansas and the former
Trump Administration press secretary the
Biden Administration is doubling down on
crazy she accused the White House of
being more interested in quote woke
fantasies than in the hard realities
Americans face I'm the first woman to
lead my state
and he's the first man to surrender his
presidency to a woke mob that can't even
tell you what a woman is
one of the most unusual exchanges last
night actually came before the
president's speech it was between two
Republicans George Santos of New York
and Senator Mitt Romney of Utah Santos
was standing along the aisle you see him
there in that orange tie Romney
reportedly called him a sick puppy and
said he had no shame take a listen
given the fact that he's under ethics
investigation he should be sitting in
the back road staying quiet instead of a
parading in front of the president and
uh and and people coming into the room
Sanchez as you may recall is facing
multiple investigations into campaign
financing after a barrage of lies about
his background and his qualifications
were revealed after he was elected Tony
a private moment there of disagreement
between the two members of Congress
Nancy thank you very much